[Musique]
drieu godefridi bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france alors qu'hier finalement les
démocrates ont salué l'action de donald
trump notamment vis-à-vis de la chine la
fermeté vis-à-vis de la chine
finalement un bilan pas si noir que ça
reconnaissent aujourd'hui les démocrates
c'est à dire que au cas du fracas de la
dette de la récente campagne et ses
développements en ce qui concerne le
dépouillement on revient en maintenant
un certain nombre de choses qui sont
plus ordinaire la reconnaissance par
l'administration entrante d'un certain
nombre de réalisations pour ne pas dire
succès de l'administration sortante et à
le fait que l'administration sortante
commence déjà par reconnaître et ensuite
souhaité bonne chance
je dirais à l'administration entrante il
est évident que la thèse qui consiste à
diaboliser l'ensemble du personnage
preuves et de l'intégralité des
traîneaux bose objectivement réalisation
de ces quatre années de mandat n'était
pas total il fallait bien un moment
reconnaître qu'il y aura de la
continuité dans un certain nombre de
dossiers et donc cela vu chips facto à
reconnaître que la précédente
administration a fait du bon travail
justement de la continuité sur un nombre
un certain nombre de dossiers on pense à
l'iran on pense à la question du climat
aussi qu'est ce qui va changer
finalement maintenant avec la demi soeur
ou trump sur le plan international là
vous prenez précisément deux exemples
sur lesquels il y aura problème
probablement parce qu'on ne peut pas
encore parler de certitudes de ce que
fera la nouvelle administration une
rupture totale avec l'administration
précédente puisque sur l'iran le
positions entre les deux administrations
donc oui dans le grand celle de monsieur
obama ait cédé de sucre ensuite été
radical il semble qu'il y aura un retour
à une
d'accord de rapprochement jeudi veut
avec les manches ce qui pourrait se
faire aux dépens de tout ce que tron a
construit évidemment dans la région et
sur le climat pareil le petit soirée
radical puisque vous aviez un hacker de
paris à l'époque baba trump on est en a
sorti les états unis et selon toute
vraisemblance biden à l'intention d'y
annuler son pays donc les options d'un
domaine international sur les deux
dossiers dont vous donner l'exemple sont
sont a priori aux antipodes de celle de
l'administration précédente alors
l'investiture aujourd'hui de joe biden
se fera sur le thème de l'amérique unis
sans la présence de donald trump une
bonne chose cette absence avait déclaré
d'ailleurs je baille donne on en est
loin aujourd'hui de cette unité
finalement voulu par par joe biden ou
finalement l'attitude de donald trump
est ce qu'elle va pouvoir apaiser des
choses avec son discours hier c'est ça
me paraît très difficile à pronostiquer
autant en effectivement si on en juge
parce qu'il y avait des objectifs si on
en juge par le nombre de promesses de
campagne qui ont été réalisés par le
prisme notre hub à son mandat avec un
succès absolument et touche soufflons
autant il paraît difficile de contester
que sa sortie de la maison blanche ne se
fait pas dans des conditions qui sont
très favorables
en l'occurrence depuis le 3 novembre
jour de l'élection il ya eu des
contestations il y a eu énormément de
bruit de fracas d'argent également levé
par la papaye trump pour contester le
résultat des élections
tout cela n'a passé que 1 couronnée de
succès et donc il est très difficile à
l'heure actuelle de pronostiquer je
dirai ce que sera l'avenir peuls type de
deux lettres jeu vous proposera
peut-être le voir un cc z'images ces
images de milieu de drapeaux pour
remplacer la foule lors de l'investiture
pandémie et sécurité oblige alors des
images encore impensable il ya quelques
années aux états unis qu'est ce qu'elle
révèle finalement du contexte si
particulier de cette investiture
elles veulent une manière de
ranspach à être dans ce chef de monsieur
miles kane qui avait rechigné à
organiser des meetings de campagne au
nom de la critique est vide et qui
semble ici s'inscrit à jeudi heure dans
la continuité et maintenant je crois
qu'il faut voir au delà de ces drapeaux
autre chose que d'un modeste simple
jeudi avec une volonté effectivement de
rassembler le peuple américain autour de
ce qui symbolise le mieux son 8e c'était
vivre le drapeau des etats unis ce qui
est peut-être plus significatif c'est la
présence absolument massif de forces de
sécurité dans la dombes d'en haut ça au
sein de l'un d'eux la capitale
américaine
autour du capitole à et honda ce soulier
non seulement évidemment de l'attak tout
intéressant du calcul ou également du
fait que lors de la précédente
investiture celle de monsieur trump il y
avait eu des et le terrible dans la
capitale américaine et donc chez cette
espèce de manifestation de force je le
veux et le fruit de ces de ces deux
réalités précédente alors donald trump a
par ailleurs vanté le fait de n'avoir
déclenché aucune guerre joe biden lui
avait annoncé le retour de l'amérique
comme étant le gendarme du monde alors à
quoi s'attendre ça veut dire quoi le
gendarme du monde avec joe biden d'abord
à titre tout à fait personnel et des
listes j'ai toujours trouvé cette
expression de gendarme du monde
terriblement arrogant terriblement
présomptueux il ya quelle est cette
nation qui se prétend qui se prétend
choisi élu par dieu pour gendarmes et le
monde je trouve l'expression même s'il
désigne un certain nombre de réalités
qui tendent elles peuvent paraître dit à
tes souhaits talent je trouve
l'expression on peut parler d'ingérence
finalement c'est ce que ça veut dire
derrière je ne sais pas à d'autres
gendarmes du monde
ça annonce finalement leur tour un
certain nombre d'options géopolitique et
géostratégie qui était celle de
l'administration d'obama ses fêlures
probablement une manière d'
interventionnisme dans les dossiers mais
ce qui frappe surtout si vous voulez
avec cette politique à l'époque de
ballon reprend finalement
c'est d'abord l'arrogance d'un président
choisi tom également le fait que le
monde a changé et que l'on les états
unis ne sont plus capables de projeter
leur puissance militaire tout à fait
considérable dans le monde avec peu de
résistance comme c'était le cas au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et donc tout ce à quoi cela aboutit à
l'époque de monsieur obama est l'un des
pires belliciste finalement de la
présidence américaine de 1945 c'était
multiplication de conflits aux quatre
coins du monde monsieur obama a ordonné
jeudi vers le bombardement toujours nom
d'un certain nombre de principes mots
d'un grand nombre de populations ont
finalement quel pays et de territoires
tard mule aux quatre coins de la planète
donc c'est là un dossier sur lequel on
semble vouloir affirmer une grande
rupture avec l'administration précédente
qui effectivement avait entamé aucune
guerre est-ce que cela crée hallyday ce
que cela laisse présager des
améliorations dans le monde
je n'en suis pas certain le dossier
iranien est très intéressant parce que
indépendamment des options g politiques
sous-jacentes
obama avait totalement échoué dans la
région la nation trump a réussi à la
veille de la révolution et la réussite
avec tous ces accords de paix avec
israël
vouloir revenir en arrière si lyon on
arrive malheureusement au terme du temps
qui nous est imparti on reviendra avec
vous très certainement dans les jours
qui viennent sur la relation etats unis
iran tout cas merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin pour la matinale vers les
franges le rappelle vous êtes
spécialiste des états unis est également
auteur de reload comment l'amérique
invente le siècle